.
* Sanfte Musik *
Otmar Gemperli
ist in die Schweiz zurückgekehrt.
Er brauchte eine Auszeit.
Ich bin eigentlich ein
sehr zielstrebiger, starker Mensch,
der sehr viel verkraften kann.
Aber plötzlich war es,
als hätte mir jemand
den Stecker gezogen und gesagt:
"Stopp, es ist genug."
Ich stand im Restaurant und
fragte mich: "Was mache ich hier?"
Es war ganz seltsam.
Allein auf Mallorca geblieben
ist sein Freund Gabor Balogh.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich vermisse ihn sehr.
In diesen acht Jahren
waren wir immer zusammen.
Wann Otmar zurückkommen wird,
ist ungewiss.
Dabei hatte alles so gut angefangen.
Ein eigenes Restaurant -
dafür hat Otmar alles investiert.
Die Umbauarbeiten sind streng,
der Zeitplan eng.
Wenn man etwas vorhat,
muss man vorwärtsmachen.
Ja, das ist jetzt passiert.
Bald schon liegen die Nerven blank.
- Er tat sich weh.
Nun haben wir geöffnet.
Die Gäste können kommen.
Einmal komplett öffnen.
- Gabor ist neu im Gastgewerbe.
Alle unterstützen ihn.
Als ich die Tabletts hielt,
zitterte meine Hand.
Wer hat die Spaghetti?
Otmar dagegen ist ein Profi.
Die Eröffnung ist ein Erfolg.
Wir haben bereits vieles optimiert.
Es ist eine gemütliche Stimmung.
Auf Island,
jenseits von allem Trubel,
haben zwei Schweizer
ihr Paradies gefunden.
Steff und Isabelle Felix
haben hier eine Ferien-Lodge gekauft.
Euer Zimmer.
Schön, was?
- Mhm.
Sie vergrössern ihren Traum
um drei weitere Ferienhäuschen.
Putzen, bauen,
die Zimmerleute bewirten -
es ist eine anstrengende Zeit.
Seit wir auf dieser Insel sind,
ist schuften angesagt.
Oh, schau mal.
In den Sonnenstaat Florida
ist Familie Tscharner gezogen.
Wir können es noch nicht glauben.
- Jetzt wohnen wir am Meer.
Die Eltern treiben ihr Geschäft
voran: Häuser sanieren und vermieten.
No problem, nicht wahr?
Achtung, Schätzchen.
Lily Rose hat ihren ersten Schultag.
Aber sie wird falsch eingestuft.
Oh.
Sie ist in der 2.
anstatt in der 1. Klasse.
Für das Mädchen
bricht die Welt zusammen.
* Weinen *
# Uf u dervo, yeah.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Am nächsten Morgen in Florida:
Lily Rose hat sich wieder beruhigt.
Komm, setz dich kurz hin.
Oh, es kommt wieder
kalte Luft aus der Lüftung.
Die Freude auf die Fahrt
mit dem Schulbus
hat das Drama
am Vorabend vergessen lassen.
Oh, der Schulbus!
Wieso kommt der jetzt schon?
Das sind Clowns.
Ah, diese doofe Tür!
Muss ich schon gehen?
- I don't know.
Lily, Schuhe anziehen,
Schuhe anziehen.
Sie sagte,
er sei um Viertel nach hier.
Sie soll sich eine Jacke anziehen.
Ich sage Bescheid.
Okay.
(Busfahrerin)
Lily Rose.
- (Busfahrerin) Lily Rose.
Möchtest du mal reinschauen?
Du darfst sicher kurz reinschauen.
Schau mal.
Wow, sie ist die Erste im Schulbus.
Wo ist sie?
- Wo ist sie?
Dort hinten ist sie, dort unten.
Bye-bye.
- Bye-bye.
Geschafft -
Lily Rose sitzt im Schulbus.
Tschüss, Schatz.
- Tschüss.- Tschüss.
Wow!
Doch in welcher Klasse
wird sie heute landen?
Denn noch hat Melanie auf die Mail,
die sie am Vorabend
an die Schulleitung geschickt hatte,
keine Antwort bekommen.
* Handyklingeln *
(Frau)
Hi.
Sorry.
Yes.
Okay.
Thank you.
Sie erhielten die E-Mail und
nahmen die Sache gleich in die Hand.
Lily Rose ist nun in der 1. Klasse.
- Oh, cool.
Wenn wir noch lange Gespräche
hätten führen müssen ...
Ich bin richtig froh.
Wir haben uns totale Sorgen gemacht.
- Ja.
Ich bin gespannt, was
für Hausaufgaben sie heute kriegt.
* Sanfte Musik
mit mystischem Frauengesang *
Auf Island ist etwas Ruhe eingekehrt.
Der Winter ist da.
Die Natur
zeigt sich in stiller Schönheit.
Nur die Auswanderer
sind ununterbrochen dran.
* Trommelnde Musik
mit mystischem Frauengesang *
Oh, der Wind!
* Isabelle und Steff lachen. *
Hündchen Theo ist immer da,
wo seine Leute sind.
Okay?
- Ja.
Geht's?
Heute sind Pakete
mit den Möbeln für die Tiny-Häuser
aus Reykjavik angekommen.
Noch ein wenig.
- Warte.
Gut, es hält.
29 Stück.
Muskelkater haben wir
schon lange nicht mehr.
* Sie lacht. *
Wir sind stark geworden.
Im Herbst hatte eine Truppe Schweizer
Zimmerleute die Häuschen aufgebaut.
In gerade mal drei Wochen
waren die Rohbauten erstellt.
Was ist wohl in diesen Paketen?
Die Dinger sind schwer.
Komm, ich nehme sie.
Die Zimmerleute
reisten in die Schweiz zurück
und für Isabelle und Steff
begann der Innenausbau.
Ich komme.
Es passt noch nicht durch.
Warte.
Jetzt.
- Ja, jetzt ist es gut.
Warte, so.
- Ja.
Geh etwas nach hinten.
Um die Ecke, wenn's geht,
in Richtung Ausgang.
Der Ausgang ist dort.
- Ja.
Sie verlegten Holzböden,
bauten die Heizung
und die Einbauschränke ein.
Während Wochen schon
sind sie am Schuften.
Wir sind zurzeit sehr zufrieden,
wie sich das Ganze entwickelt hat.
Bis jetzt haben wir
noch nichts entdeckt,
was wir komplett ändern müssten.
Wir hätten das Cheminée
vielleicht etwas anders platziert,
vielleicht etwas mehr hier
oder dort.
Im Nachhinein
hätten wir die drei Häuser
vielleicht
alle gleich gross gemacht.
Aber wir sind total zufrieden
und happy mit dem Istzustand.
* Bohrgeräusch *
Heute montieren sie eine Küche.
Jetzt ...
- Jetzt brauchst du den Kleinen?
Ja, für die Wasserleitungen.
Als leidenschaftlicher Handwerker
war für Steff klar:
Den Innenausbau
wollen sie selbst machen.
Isabelle war jahrelang als Kauffrau
in der Immobilienbranche tätig.
Für sie
ist diese Arbeit komplett neu.
Mittlerweile habe ich
sehr viel dazugelernt.
Anfangs stand ich jeweils hier
und wusste nicht ...
Ich verstand
viele Fachausdrücke nicht.
Aber inzwischen weiss ich, was
er braucht, wenn er um etwas bittet.
Ich habe viel gelernt.
Ein Handwerker sagt: "Bring mir
dies, bring mir jenes."
Ich wusste jeweils nicht,
was gemeint war.
* Isabelle lacht. *
Er ist schon zufrieden mit mir.
Es bleibt ihm nichts anderes übrig.
Sonst ist ja niemand da.
Das Liebespaar
ist auch ein Arbeitsteam geworden.
Gut so?
- Ja, das reicht.
Manchmal werde ich schon laut,
wenn ich finde,
dass etwas nicht gut läuft.
Aber im Grossen und Ganzen haben wir
uns in diesen sieben Jahren ...
... ziemlich gut kennengelernt,
sodass wir wissen, wie
die andere Person manchmal reagiert.
Das ist auch gut so. Das ist nötig.
Wir müssen ...
Wir sind aufeinander angewiesen.
Das dürfen wir nicht vergessen.
Wir sind ein Zweierteam.
Theo ist auch noch
eine halbe Person,
aber der sagt zum Glück nicht viel.
Es ist ja nicht so schwer.
- Nein.
Sicher ist:
Ihr gemeinsamer Arbeitsplatz
hat eine spektakuläre Aussicht.
Noch etwas rüber, gut.
* Sägegeräusch *
In gut drei Monaten sollen auch Gäste
hier den Ausblick geniessen.
Im Touristendörfchen Cala Rajada
ist die Saison bestens angelaufen.
Das Ostergeschäft war top.
Das Team rund um Gabor
hat einen neuen Kellner,
und noch immer mit dabei ist die
bisherige Besitzerin Corinna Hauer.
Trotz Otmars Abwesenheit
läuft es rund.
Hi, everyone.
Okay, super, thank you.
Ich habe nur Rosé gesehen.
- Hier ist eine Flasche.
Es muss immer von allem etwas
hinten kalt gestellt werden.
Wenn nicht, stell etwas kalt.
- Habe ich gemacht.
Dass er für zwei Wochen weg ist,
ist nicht so schlimm.
Aber mehr
würde ich nicht akzeptieren.
Als Gabor realisiert hatte,
wie erschöpft
und geradezu fertig sein Freund war,
hat er ihn ermuntert,
in die Schweiz zu fahren.
Bei seiner Familie
soll er Kraft für die
bevorstehende Sommersaison tanken.
Yeah, that's fine, thank you.
- Danke.
Thank you very much.
- Cheers.
Die ganze Brisas-Truppe
hält Otmar den Rücken frei.
Es hat auch vorher funktioniert.
Das Team
ist noch so ziemlich dasselbe.
Daher wird es
auch weiterhin funktionieren -
ob mit oder ohne Otmar.
Ähm ...
Es war natürlich alles
etwas anders gedacht und vereinbart,
aber die Umstände
sind jetzt halt so.
Es läuft nie alles so wie geplant.
Man macht halt, was man machen muss,
und es geht weiter.
Der Betrieb soll weitergehen,
so wie es Otmar aufgegleist hat.
Es ist alles in Ordnung.
- Okay.
Danke.
- Danke dir.
Gute Erholung.
- Danke.
Nach dem Mittagservice
hat Gabor Zimmerstunde.
Am anderen Ende von Cala Rajada
ist sein Zuhause.
Im lebendigen Restaurantalltag,
mit den Kollegen und Gästen,
hat Gabor kaum Zeit,
Otmar zu vermissen.
Momentan kommt alles hier rein.
Doch zu Hause in der einsamen
Wohnung, da fehlt er ihm sehr.
Das Schlimmste ist,
allein zu schlafen. Ich hasse das.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Mario lacht. *
Juhu!
Die Tscharners sind beruhigt.
Töchterchen Lily Roses
zweiter Schulstart ist geglückt.
An einer Bucht in Panacea,
ganz in der Nähe des Meeres,
haben sie ein sog. Condo erworben.
Dieses müssen sie nicht von Grund auf
sanieren, sondern können es
bald zur Vermietung ausschreiben.
Sie wollen endlich Geld verdienen.
Noch einmal kontrollieren sie,
was dringend erneuert werden muss.
Hier ist genug Platz,
um es so zu machen.
* Eines der Kinder kreischt. *
* Mario lacht. *
Dann könnte man
einen Eingangsbereich einrichten.
Ich hatte es
nicht mehr so genau in Erinnerung.
Das letzte Mal führten sich
die Kinder so schlimm auf.
Und Ruby Sue fiel draussen
noch die Treppe runter.
Ja, Ruby Sue fiel draussen ...
* Er lacht. *
Der ist noch gut.
Ja, aber ein neuer Herd
und ein neuer Geschirrspüler.- Ja.
Auch raus sollen Deko
und die behäbige Einrichtung.
Sie soll leichten Möbeln
und bunten Kissen Platz machen.
Ein bisschen ausgefallen,
aber trotzdem gemütlich soll es
werden, der typische Boho-Style eben.
Wow!
- Wo sind die Delfine?
Bereits perfekt ist die Aussicht.
Where are the dolphins?
Hier habe ich nicht so viel Arbeit.
Diese Wohnung
kann ich wohl allein herrichten,
während Mario
auf der anderen Seite der Brücke,
in Alligator Point, arbeitet.
Dort wohnten wir anfangs.
Dort gibt es noch etwas mehr Arbeit.
Wir werden hier sicher bis Mitte
oder Ende Februar fertig sein,
sodass wir
die Wohnung vermieten können.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Trotz Meeresnähe: Standardgemäss
gehört zum Condo ein Swimmingpool.
(Melanie)
Die Abgeschiedenheit Islands
kennt keinen Stau.
Auf der halbstündigen Fahrt
in die Stadt
kommt Isabelle
gerade mal ein Auto entgegen.
Feierabendverkehr.
Sie ist unterwegs in den Sprachkurs.
Natürlich macht es Spass,
das ist kein Thema.
Es ist einfach ...
Ich muss einfach wieder lernen.
Das bin ich nicht mehr gewohnt.
Ich war seit 25 Jahren
nicht mehr in der Schule.
Das ist eine neue Herausforderung,
der ich mich stelle.
Aber es ist gut.
Es ist lustig.
Egilsstadir ist die grösste Stadt
im Osten Islands.
Durch sie führt auch die beliebte
Route 1 - die Ringstrasse.
Sie geht einmal rund um die Insel.
Seit Jahren zieht Island
immer mehr Touristen an,
und viele Europäer
lassen sich hier nieder.
Die Wirtschaft floriert,
hier gibt es Arbeit.
Entsprechend gut besucht
sind die Sprachkurse.
(Isländisch)
Die Lehrerin Cynthia Ósk Crawford
ist aus den USA.
(Englisch)
(Isländisch)
Der Horror, was?
Wenn man die verschiedenen
Buchstaben zusammensetzt,
werden sie ganz anders ausgesprochen
als geschrieben.
Es ist schon eine Challenge.
Thad kemur smátt og smátt,
wie man so schön sagt:
Es kommt mehr und mehr.
(Englisch)
* Gemütliche Musik *
So.
Irgendwann einmal wird auch Steff
die Sprache lernen müssen.
Doch noch fehlt ihm die Musse.
Mal schauen, wann sie angerufen hat.
Die beiden wissen immer,
wo der andere sich aufhält.
Um sieben nach. Dann sollte sie
in etwa 4 Min. hier sein.
Dann ist die Pasta al dente.
Eine gefüllte Vorratskammer
ist auf Island ein Muss.
Das Inselklima ist rau.
Besonders im Winter
schlägt das Wetter blitzartig um
und dann sind die Strassen
nicht mehr passierbar.
Innert Kürze ist man eingeschneit.
Ich mache mir schon Sorgen,
wenn das Wetter nicht gut ist
oder die Strassen
nicht gut befahrbar sind.
Denn sie fährt nicht so gern
bei Schnee und Eis.
Wenn sie dann zur Schule muss,
ist das für sie
eine riesige Herausforderung.
Dann mache ich mir schon ...
Dann will ich wissen,
wann sie losfährt,
damit ich weiss,
wo sie ungefähr ist.
Aber ich habe ja ein Auto und
könnte ihr jederzeit entgegenfahren.
Deshalb frage ich auch immer,
auf welcher Seeseite sie fährt,
damit ich weiss, wo ich suchen muss,
wenn etwas wäre.
Hello.
- Hi.
Wir können essen.
Ziehst du den Mantel aus?- Ja.
* Isabelle seufzt. *
Bist du müde?- Mhm.
Dein Rücken?
- Nicht gut.
Schmerzen?
- Ja. Du darfst mich massieren.
Hier?
Und manchmal
meldet sich halt doch der Körper:
Kein Muskelkater zwar,
aber eine Verspannung.
* Sanfte Musik *
Es gibt nur eins:
mehr Sofa-Schachteln schleppen.
Dann verschwindet das wieder.
- Mhm.
Betonieren wäre auch gut.
- Du darfst heute Abend nochmals.
Theo, isst du schon? Ist es lecker?
* Gemütliche Musik *
Der Frühling
ist die schönste Zeit auf Mallorca.
Viel Sonnenschein und kaum Touristen.
Jahr für Jahr haben
Otmar und Gabor die Insel bereist.
Hierher auszuwandern,
war immer schon Otmars Traum.
* Sanfte Musik *
Doch nun ist Gabor allein hier.
Hallo.
- (Mann) Hello, Gabor.
Okay.
Das habe ich auch
hier auf Mallorca stechen lassen,
als wir das erste Mal
in Palma waren.
Ja.
Das wird für immer bleiben.
(Englisch)
Ja.
Die Freude an Tattoos ist etwas, was
Gabor und Otmar auch gemeinsam haben.
Ja.
Gabor
stammt aus einer grossen Familie.
Allein zu sein und sich gar einsam
zu fühlen, das ist neu für ihn.
Er ist in der Schweiz,
bei seiner Familie,
und kann sich mit Freunden treffen.
Ich habe hier niemanden,
nur Ronaldo, den Hund.
Ich frage immer:
"Wann kommst du zurück?"
Dann sagt er: "Bald."
Ich sagte: "Bald kann
auch in ein paar Monaten sein."
Aber das hoffe ich nicht.
Das Tattoo - sechs Vögelchen -
ist perfekt.
Thank you so much.
* Entspannte Musik *
Es ist sehr schön.
Es gefällt mir sehr.
Dass ihn das Leben einmal
auf eine Ferieninsel führen würde,
damit hat der gebürtige Ungar
nicht gerechnet.
Um ganz ehrlich zu sein,
war es Otmars Plan und Otmars Traum,
hierherzukommen.
Ich wollte ja
in der Schweiz bleiben.
Ich hatte angefangen,
dort mein Leben aufzubauen.
Und, äh ...
Wie soll ich es sagen?
Ich wollte dort leben.
Er sagte immer,
dass das sein Traum sei.
Dann sagte ich: "Okay, ich komme
mit, weil wir zusammengehören."
Es ist nicht nur die Einsamkeit,
die Gabor nun zu schaffen macht.
Er ist auch verunsichert.
Wann wird Otmar zurückkommen?
Plötzlich
hängt vieles in der Schwebe.
Ich habe mich so darauf gefreut,
selbst etwas
auf die Beine zu stellen.
Nicht alle haben die Chance,
ihr eigener Chef zu sein.
Irgendwie fühle ich mich,
als wäre mir das weggenommen worden.
Mein Wunsch ist -
egal ob hier oder in der Schweiz -,
dass ich mein Leben zurückkriege,
so wie es in der Schweiz war.
Ich arbeitete und hatte Pläne.
Es war alles schön gradlinig.
Jetzt ist es ein Auf und Ab.
Ich möchte mich auch mal
irgendwo zu Hause fühlen.
Ich war acht Jahre lang
in der Schweiz.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dort zu leben, bis ich sterbe.
Jetzt bin ich hier
und vielleicht kehre ich
wieder in die Schweiz zurück.
Ja. Ich möchte wieder
irgendwo zu Hause sein.
Ja.
* Sanfte Musik *
Oi-oi-oi.
Manche Dinge
brauchen einfach etwas länger.
Oh, nein!
Es ist gut zu wissen, dass ...
Es ist alles unter Wasser.
Aber jetzt ist es ...
* Lautes Donnern *
Ich glaube, wir müssen reingehen.
Die Vermietung von Tscharners
Mobile Home in Alligator Point
hat sich wegen
eines Wasserschadens verzögert.
Für einmal arbeitet Mario allein.
Er war jahrelang technischer Leiter
eines Elektrizitätswerks
und hat im Wesentlichen
immer in einem Team gearbeitet.
Die Teamarbeit
vermisse ich schon ein bisschen.
Wir hatten ein super Team.
In Azmoos waren tolle Leute im Team.
Es war schön,
miteinander zu arbeiten.
Nun besteht das Team
aus mir und meiner Frau.
Das ist etwas komplett anderes.
Manchmal denke ich schon an
die schöne Zeit in Azmoos zurück.
Aber hier benötigen wir
ja sowieso auch Angestellte.
Zurzeit sehe ich mich
nach jemandem um,
der Handlanger-Aufgaben
für mich übernehmen könnte.
Die Rheintaler
sind mit einem Investorenvisum
in die USA eingereist.
Bald schon müssen sie Angestellte
beschäftigen. Das ist eine Auflage.
Ansonsten würde
ihr Visum nicht erneuert werden.
Am Coastal Highway - wenige Kilometer
vom Mobile Home entfernt -,
gibt es einen vorzüglichen Foodtruck,
den Huttons's Seafood & More.
What?
Isst du den Corn Dog?
Ja.
- Aber du isst ihn?
Nicht so wie letztes Mal, okay?
For Daddy ...
He likes the grouper sandwich.
Für Mario gibt es ein Fischsandwich.
Ruby Sue liebt den Corn Dog -
ein Würstchen im Maismantel.
(Frau) Thank you, have a good day.
- Thank you, you too. Bye-bye.
Nur selten
kauft Melanie das Mittagessen ein.
Meistens nimmt sie es
von zu Hause mit.
Ja, ja.
- Hallo.
Hallo.
- Kuckuck!
Denn das ist auch eine Kostenfrage:
Als Jungunternehmer müssen sie
ihre Ausgaben im Auge behalten.
Seit ihrer Ankunft in den USA
haben sie nur Auslagen.
Es braucht halt einiges,
bis das Ganze in Gang kommt.
Aber das ist immer so,
wenn man sich selbstständig macht -
auch in der Schweiz.
Das Leben ist gleich teuer oder
sogar teurer als in der Schweiz.
Das sind sich viele nicht bewusst.
Die Lebensmittel sind gleich teuer
oder fast teurer.
Wir verliessen die Schweiz zum Glück
mit einem guten Polster.
Ohne dieses Polster wird es schwie-
rig, in den USA Fuss zu fassen.
Ja, ja.
Aber wir können uns
noch nicht beklagen.
Wir nagen noch nicht am Hungertuch.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Gemütliche Musik *
Theo weiss, wo es am Schönsten ist.
Besonders, wenn nebenan im Büro
Isabelle arbeitet.
Die Buchhaltung und das ganze
Gästemanagement der Hengifosslodge
ist ihr Aufgabengebiet.
Die letzte Saison zeigte uns,
dass diese Gegend auch gefragt ist.
Diese Gegend ist nicht unbedingt
an den grossen Touristenstrom
angeschlossen.
In der letzten Saison merkten wir,
dass wirklich
eine Nachfrage vorhanden ist.
Das verschafft uns etwas Luft,
um zu sagen:
"Die nächste Saison
wird noch besser."
Jetzt gehen wir hoch. Komm.
Ist es zu kalt? Nein, nein.
Komm, wir gehen spazieren, komm.
Jetzt. Wir gehen hoch zur Quelle.
Vom warmen Bett raus in die Kälte:
ein drastischer Schritt.
Okay? Gehen wir hoch? Hm?
Komm, wir sehen es uns an.
Komm.
* Piff *
* Gemütliche Musik *
Theo!
* Pfiff *
Noch haben
die neuen Ferienhäuschen kein Wasser.
In Island sind Landbesitzer
selbst dafür verantwortlich,
woher sie Wasser bekommen.
Komm.
Man kann nach Grundwasser bohren.
Kostenpunkt: rund 70'000 Fr.
Oder man hat Glück
und findet auch so eine Quelle.
Steff hat ein Wasserloch entdeckt -
bereits im Frühjahr.
Die Einheimischen sagen,
wenn das Wasser im ...
Wir hatten ja -28 °C.
Hier lag der Schnee so hoch.
Das Loch selbst
war jedoch nicht gefroren.
Nicht mal das Wasser war gefroren.
Wenn das Wasser nicht gefriert,
kommt es aus dem Boden.
Dann ist es
kein Oberflächenwasser mehr.
Die Chancen stehen gut,
dass es eine Quelle ist.
Nur wie potent sie ist,
das wird sich erst zeigen.
Wir brauchen ja
nicht so viel Wasser.
D.h., der Hauptfluss ist morgens,
wenn die Leute duschen,
sich die Zähne putzen,
auf die Toilette gehen etc.
Danach ist das Haus leer.
Ab 16 oder 17 Uhr,
wenn die Leute ankommen,
benötigen wir wieder Wasser,
wenn sie duschen, sich die Zähne
putzen, auf die Toilette gehen etc.
Danach kann sich das Wasserreservoir
die ganze Nacht lang auffüllen.
Bei jeder Witterung -
ob Wärme oder Eiseskälte -,
während Monaten schon
checkt Steff die Lage.
In der Schweiz gefielen mir immer
die Regionen ab der Waldgrenze,
dort, wo der Wald aufhört.
Das ist in Island genau so.
Wir leben auf der Waldgrenze.
Für mich ist das perfekt.
Es ist karg, grob und steinig.
Das ist spannend.
* Entspannte Musik *
In Meeresnähe hingegen hat sich
Familie Tscharner niedergelassen.
Dazu gehört ein Boot.
Bald schon wollen sie
auch Spritztouren anbieten.
Wo ist denn jetzt Mama?
Weisst du das?
Mama?
Sie kommt bestimmt gleich wieder.
Und die Mama
hat eine weitere Geschäftsidee.
Diese wollen sie heute testen.
- Ist das eine Kerze?
Die Tscharners haben viele Ideen -
und sie nehmen sich die Freiheit,
alles auszuprobieren.
Wir dachten, wir inserieren
die Wohnung, das Condo, mal
und dann dauert es bestimmt ein
paar Wochen, bis sich jemand meldet.
Aber wir hatten sofort Buchungen,
und zwar viele.
Diesen und nächsten Monat
ist es ausgebucht.
Das hätten wir nicht erwartet.
Ich erwartete für den Anfang
einen Leerstand von etwa 50 %.
Aber unsere Erwartungen
wurden weit übertroffen.
Bei anderen Dingen hingegen
benötigt man einfach Geduld.
Die Arbeit
mit dem Vergnügen verbinden.
Die Bootstour geht nach Dog Island.
Dort ist auch noch einer.
- Ja, ich sah ihn.
Und hier ist auch noch einer.
Dort oben ist der Delfin.
Papa, jetzt kannst du Vollgas geben.
- Halt dich fest.
* Melanie jauchzt. *
- Oh, fliegt dein Hut weg?
* Kreischen *
Jetzt wurdet ihr noch geduscht.
* Melanie lacht. *
Dog Island ist ein beliebtes
Ausflugsziel an der Forgotten Coast.
* Verträumte Musik *
Oh, schaut, der Krebs.
- Wow! Habt ihr das gesehen?
Weisst du was? Wir machen es anders.
Wir stellen den Bogen hierhin und
machen das Foto in diese Richtung.
Oder stört der Schaum da hinten?
- Ja, pff ...
An den einsamen Stränden
von Dog Island
wollen sie romantische
Hochzeitszeremonien anbieten.
Nochmals rundherum?
- Ich weiss es auch nicht genau.
Ich hoffe sehr,
dass die Leute das schätzen.
Wir sahen mal eine Strandhochzeit,
während der nebenan
Badegäste badeten.
Das war gar nicht schön.
Das sah furchtbar aus
und wir waren völlig schockiert.
Weisst du noch?
Ja, wir badeten gleich nebenan
und es hiess:
"Macht bitte ein bisschen Platz."
Dann begannen sie,
das Ganze aufzubauen.
Das war völlig unromantisch.
Wenn schon, müsste man das
an einem Ort wie hier machen,
wo es
noch menschenleere Strände gibt.
So. Warte, ich muss weiter rüber.
Oder geht das?
Melanie will Fotos
auf den sozialen Medien posten,
um für ihr Angebot Werbung zu machen.
Es müsste noch etwas üppiger sein,
damit es mehr hergibt.
Im Grossen und Ganzen
passt es zu meiner Vorstellung,
aber das eine oder andere
muss ich noch abändern.
* Muntere Musik *
Aus zwei Wochen sind nun
fast zwei Monate geworden,
die Otmar in der Schweiz verbringt.
Langsam
hat er wieder Boden unter den Füssen.
Eine dunkle Zeit liegt hinter ihm.
Diese begann eigentlich
schon Wochen vor der Auswanderung,
als Otmar hier in Emmenbrücke
seinen Vater beerdigen musste.
Wenig später schon ist er
mit einer grossen Trauer im Herzen
nach Mallorca aufgebrochen.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Rigoros
hat er die Trauer weggeschoben,
hatte nur ein einziges Ziel
vor Augen:
die Eröffnung seines Restaurants
auf Mallorca -
sein Lebenstraum,
in den er alles investiert hat.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Als der Druck weg war,
fiel er in ein Loch.
Das geschah eigentlich erst
eine Woche nach der Eröffnung,
in der Zeit,
in der der Alltag eingezogen wäre.
Ich war anwesend,
funktionierte aber
irgendwie nicht mehr.
Mir wurde alles zu viel -
bereits das Aufstehen morgens.
"Ach, jetzt muss ich duschen
und mich bereit machen."
Danach stand ich im Restaurant
und dachte: "Was mache ich hier?"
Natürlich hat es
auch viel mit den Dingen zu tun,
die wir in der Familie erlebten,
z.B. den Todesfall unseres Vaters.
Dann gab es noch einen weiteren
Todesfall: die Mutter des Schwagers.
Das kam einfach alles gleichzeitig
und es war einfach zu viel.
Ich denke, das trug alles dazu bei,
dass plötzlich nichts mehr ging.
Es war gar keine Zeit vorhanden,
um die Dinge zu verarbeiten -
keine.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Irgendwann kam auch der Moment,
in dem ich mich fragte:
"War es die richtige Entscheidung,
dieses Restaurant in Mallorca
zu eröffnen?"
Ich begann, alles zu hinterfragen
und schaute mir die Pläne an,
die ich gemacht hatte,
und die Fotos und Videos des Umbaus.
Ich versuchte,
mich an der Tatsache festzuhalten,
dass es seit mehr als 20 Jahren
mein Traum ist,
ein Restaurant in Mallorca
zu eröffnen.
Es kann nicht sein, dass ich ihn
wegen dieses Vorfalls jetzt aufgebe.
Ich bin froh,
dass sich die Mitarbeiter sehr gut
um den Betrieb gekümmert haben,
weil es ihnen wichtig ist,
dass es gut weitergeht.
Sie versuchten,
das Ganze so weiterzuführen,
wie ich es in dieser kurzen Zeit
aufgebaut hatte.
Ich bin natürlich auch froh,
dass sich Corinna weiterhin
gut um den Betrieb kümmerte
und das Organisatorische übernahm.
* Sanfte Musik *
Nun fühlt er sich
wieder kräftig genug,
um nach Mallorca zurückzukehren.
Spätestens beim Schneetreiben
beginnt für die Island-Auswanderer
die Badesaison.
Dann macht ein Besuch im Thermalbad
am meisten Spass.
Einmal mehr:
Auf der Strasse nach Egilsstadir
kommt ihnen
nur ein einziges Auto entgegen.
* Sanfte, mystische Klänge *
Gut 30 km von ihrem Daheim entfernt
gibt es sog. Vöks:
heisse Quellen
mitten im gefrorenen See.
(Frau, Englisch)
Okay, no problem.
- Okay, thank you, bye-bye.
Die Aussentemperatur
liegt bei knapp unter 0 °C.
Das Wasser hingegen
ist wohlige 41 °C warm.
Seit über einem Jahr schon sind die
Schweizer ununterbrochen am Arbeiten.
Freitage sind,
seit sie einen Fuss auf die Insel
gesetzt haben, gestrichen.
Diesmal haben sie
das Bad für sich allein.
Du würdest besser
in den Fluss springen.
Sie sagte, es sei zu kalt.
Wir dürfen nicht.
Wir machen ein bisschen Blödsinn.
* Gemütliche Musik *
Solche Auszeiten
muss man sich einfach nehmen.
Das muss einfach drinliegen.
Das muss auch er ...
Das sieht er auch ein.
- Ja, ja.
Ja, ja.
- Ja.
Ich bin nicht der Typ,
der 3 Std. lang im Wasser sitzt.
Nach etwa 30 Min.
habe ich meist genug.
Für mich ist das mühsam.
Wir arbeiten an drei Häusern und
das muss relativ zügig vorangehen.
Und, ja ...
Bei mir muss es
einfach schnell gehen.
Nicht wahr?
- Ich vergleiche uns mit Zügen:
Er ist ein TGV ...
... und ich bin
manchmal ein Bummelzug.
Diese Kombination
ergibt einen Intercity.
Ja.
- Dann sind wir auf gutem Weg.
Und plötzlich sind Leute da.
* Gemütliche Musik *
Das ist Island:
Zuerst starker Schneefall,
ein paar Minuten später Sonnenschein
und danach regnet es vielleicht.
So deprimiert einen das Wetter
nicht. Es ändert sich ja immer.
In der nächsten Folge
von "Auf und davon" ...
Warte.
... soll auch Ruby Sue am echten
amerikanischen Leben teilhaben.
Lily Rose ging plötzlich zur Schule
und sie war allein mit uns zu Hause.
Auch ohne Englischkenntnisse -
die Kleine findet
schon bald einen Freund.
Die Eltern
haben eine neue Geschäftsidee:
Sie bieten Campingferien
direkt auf ihrem Grundstück an.
* Mario seufzt zufrieden. *
Auf Mallorca
hat die Hochsaison begonnen.
Otmar ist wieder zurück
auf der Insel.
Es ist seltsam, wieder hier zu sein.
Ich realisierte noch nicht,
dass wir wieder hier sind.
Wir müssen kurz die Gäste begrüssen.
- Zwei Personen?
Corinna ist streng mit Otmar.
Ich brauche Taten und keine Worte.
Und jetzt mache ich die Bestellung.
Denn Otmar muss nachholen, was er
in den letzten Wochen verpasst hat.
Melody ...
Das ist diese Crema Catalana.
Bei eisigen Temperaturen
haben Isa und Steff endlich Zeit ...
Ich hoffe,
es schaukelt nicht zu sehr.
... für einen einmaligen Ausflug.
Komm rauf, komm.
- Es schaukelt etwas mehr.
Hast du gesehen, wo?
- Nein.- Komm, schau.
Da vorn, die Schwanzflosse.
# ... chöme nüm meh hei.
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024
# Uf u dervo, yeah.